Oh, my fuzzy cottontail.
Do you think she’ll have my head for being late?
No, I…
I really must be, it’s time to…
You think one of these cakes is magical?
Not that one.
Allow me to shield it from your eyes, Your Majesty.
You were born in the jungle. You were raised by wolves. So cool, by the way.
Where’s Mowgli?
Come with me, I’ll keep you safe!
Wouldn’t you love to have a dog like this?
Look at her, to your left. No, not that far. Rotate your, ugh!
If you ever come to the jungle, you’ll be my guests.
Thanks, but no thanks. I’m an inside cat now.
Have any special skills or talents?
Bull riding?
I’ll see you at high noon.
Uh, can it be three thirty. After school. Please?
Once again, the marshal needs his sidekick to save him from danger.
I’m not his sidekick.
That’s right, I work alone.
I’m his partner.
I did not need your help.
Course not.
What are these sparkles?
They’re memories left behind by other people.
It’s so strange, I’ve never met anyone who could see the sparkles.
That’s the part you find strange?
Give me a break, you can talk to ghosts.
I wouldn’t believe anything that she tells you.
These will be yummy.
They do look good.
Wait, I thought Frankenstein was a monster?
You’ve seen him too?
The only way to make my creator remorseful is to destroy all of humanity.
Okay, that’s a little much.
Where were you traveling from today when your cab broke down?
Driving around town, going wherever the fare takes me.
That’s helpful.
What are your friends like? Are they talking bears?
You sure have a colorful imagination, Donna.
You’re alive?
Yeah.
If you don’t mind, I’m at a very exciting part.
I figured it out. I’m a fictional character from a book written by an obscure writer and
I’ve been brought here by your ghost friend.
I am a little bit disappointed that I am fictitious.
You’ll always be real to us.
Thank you.
My crew disappeared. I will need a new one.
This rat alone can’t run a ship.
Who wants to walk the plank?
Ahhh!
Thanks, buddy.
I’m sorry for not being loyal to you, Santiago.
Pirates forever.
Why did Ghostwriter release these characters from the book? Maybe we need to ask!
Ghostwriter, can you hear us?
The ghost can’t but the whole city can!